-Our next guests
are both talented actresses
and real-life sisters
whose new films,
"Sister Swap:
A Hometown Holiday"
and "Sister Swap:
Christmas in the City,"
are a part of Hallmark Channel's
Countdown to Christmas.
Let's take a look.
-I was thinking,
what if I didn't go back
to Hazelwood?
-I think that's really smart.
-You don't think Mom and Dad
are going to be upset
if I stay here
for a couple more days?
-I think they'd be glad
you're trying something new.
-Oh. Sister swap! I love this!
-I do, too. Alright.
I'm going to tell Joe
that you're helping out, okay?
-Oh, no, no. Let me.
I can handle it.
-Okay. Alright.
Well, um, I love you.
Call me if anything
comes up, okay?
-I promise I will.
I love you, too.
-Bye.
-Also I'm never
giving back this coat.
-Please welcome back to the show
Kimberly Williams-Paisley
and Ashley Williams!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
-Welcome back, ladies!
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
-We're really happy to be here.
-We're so happy to be here.
-I want to clean up
a little bit,
as quickly as I can,
the weird way
we all know each other.
-Yeah.
-My sister-in-law
knows your husband,
and through that connection,
you called your sister, who's
husbands with Brad Paisley,
who then agreed to play --
-Husband's wife.
-Yes, he's your husband.
-Yes.
I think it's so nice
that you guys swap that.
You're like, "We don't --
We're not --
We don't care what it is."
-We're not into labels.
-Yeah.
So your husband, Brad Paisley,
then came and surprised my wife
at our wedding.
-With me. I came, too.
-With you.
You came, as well.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Also, you and I -- Also, you
and I went to college together.
-We did.
-But we did not know each other.
And you were
the first famous person
I saw in person,
because when you were in college
you had already been
in "Father of the Bride."
-Holy cow.
-I'm exhausted.
-You just did that.
-Are you guys okay?
-We know each other
a lot of different ways.
-Yeah, we do. We do. We do.
-And then one of the craziest
things happened, is my wife
and I came to Nashville
to see you and Brad.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you guys --
Brad came over to the hotel.
You came separately.
-We came separately.
-And then you drove home
in one car.
-Right. And I left my car.
And I said, "You guys
come visit the farm tomorrow
and just bring my car home."
-Yep.
-And then you stole the car.
-Okay.
-Okay. Back it up.
-This is not really true. But --
-I mean, it is.
That's what happened.
-We went down to the valet
and said, "We're here
for Kimberly's car."
-Yeah. Yeah, I gave you
my valet ticket.
-You gave us a ticket.
-Yeah.
-So we gave the ticket.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then my wife texted you.
-And she said,
"I love your Porsche."
-Yeah.
-And I drive
a Chevy SUV mom car.
I wrote back, "Ha ha.
LOL."
And she -- Wait. Wait.
She wrote back and went,
"Uh, you don't have a Porsche?"
And I said,
"No, I don't have a Porsche."
And then you guys were like, at,
breakfast with the nice Porsche.
-Yeah.
-And I wish I was that person
that you thought I was
for a second.
-The most embarrassing thing
was then I had to
drive a Porsche
that I now knew I had stolen...
-Right.
-...back to a hotel
without crashing it.
-Yeah.
-And then there were a few --
I realize a bunch
of clues I missed.
-Yeah.
-Which is, when Alexi got in,
there was, like, a pair
of size-14 shoes and, like --
And when I had gotten in,
I had to move the seat way up.
-Right, right. But that
could have been the valet.
-Could have been the valet.
That's true.
-Yeah. And he left
his shoes in there?
I don't know.
-But then it was nice that
when I went back and switched
and got your car, it was --
There was, like, half a salad.
-Right.
It was -- That was obvious.
You were like, "Oh, this is Kim.
This makes sense."
There was, like, half a salad
in the front seat
and NPR on the radio.
-I was like, "I can't believe we
thought the Porsche was hers."
-I can't either.
-So you guys live
in different cities now.
You're in L.A.
You're in Nashville.
And it must be so nice
to both be doing press
for this project together
and be back in New York
where you guys grew up.
-We love being back here.
-It's amazing. Yeah.
-And we are East Coast people,
through and through.
And speaking of the East Coast,
Kim just had a big birthday.
-I did.
-And the big --
-It had to do with
where we're from.
-Yeah.
-So let me back up.
So, in sixth grade,
I went to P.S. 8 in Yonkers.
-Okay.
-P.S. 8.
And I was in love
with Frankie Dibona.
-Okay.
-He was my first crush.
-Who wasn't, in Yonkers?
-Seriously.
Frankie was adorable.
He was my first crush.
-So hot.
-And one day -- one day
in school he said, "I'm going
to kiss you after school."
And I was like, "Okay."
And --
-I do want to give everybody
a little visual of Frankie.
-That's Frankie!
-Frankie!
-That's Kim.
-Okay, so Frankie --
-And that's Stacy.
-And that's Plan B
in case you said no.
-Yes! Yes!
-"Frankie Dibona
has always got two options!"
-Yes. Yes. He did.
He had a few options.
So he goes,
"I'm going to kiss you
for ten seconds after school."
And Stacy's like, "I'll count."
And so I was like, "Okay."
So at the end of the day,
I go outside,
and there's Frankie
in the schoolyard
eating Cheez Doodles.
And he goes, "Are you ready?"
And I said, "But you're
eating Cheez Doodles."
And he says, "It don't matter."
He goes, "It don't matter.
Not the way I kiss."
And then he goes like --
you know, like, smack kiss
for ten seconds.
And Stacy goes,
"One, two, three..."
She was chewing gum.
She got all the way to ten.
Happiest day of my life.
So...
-So you knew then --
You knew this was a piece
of her personal history.
-This story is family legacy
at this point, right?
-Yeah, I mean,
kids quote Frankie Dibona.
Everyone's like, "It don't
matter. It don't matter."
-"It don't matter."
-Yeah.
So I just decided
that, for Kim's birthday,
I was going to get back
in touch with Frank Dibona.
-Yes!
-'Cause --
I mean, what other option
was there for her birthday?
-Right, right.
-Sure.
-So I googled every single
Frank Dibona in North America.
-Right.
-And there are a lot.
-Yeah.
-So I talked to somebody
in Seattle.
I talked to somebody in Boston.
-You were cold-calling Dibonas?
-Cold-calling Frankie Dibonas.
I talked to these people
in the Midwest
who are still calling me.
So, finally,
I find Frank Dibona,
who happens to run
a very successful
auto-mechanic shop in Yonkers.
-Yeah.
-And he answers the phone.
And he goes, "Yeah?"
And I was like, "Um, hi.
Is this Frank Dibona?
Did you kiss a girl named
Kim Williams in sixth grade?"
And he goes,
"Who wants to know?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like -- I was like,
"Oh, my gosh. I'm in."
I was like, "Hi, Frank.
My name is Ashley.
You don't know me. But my sister
has a big birthday.
And I was wondering
if I can convince you
to make a happy-birthday video
because she was in love
with you in sixth grade."
And he said, "Wait. Hold --
Hold on one second."
He goes, "Yeah, you tell
that lady with the Subaru
that I'm not gonna
fix her bumper."
[ Laughter ]
So he comes back,
and I'm so nervous.
So I was like, "So, anyway.
Can -- Can you make this happy
birthday video for my sister?"
And he goes, "You know what?
I don't want no trouble.
Like, who's her husband?
Like, I don't want
to make anybody jealous."
And I was like --
-Clearly, he's not a fan.
Like, "I assure you
that her husband
is very confident
in his marriage."
And, uh, so, anyway, he made
this incredible, loving,
hilarious happy-birthday video
for my sister.
And we couldn't be there
the night
that it was presented to you,
but I was there on FaceTime.
And I think we have a photo
of the moment of the big reveal.
-This is so wonderful.
-So this is Kim sitting there.
-This is me, having nailed it.
And there is Kim.
-Best birthday ever.
-I nailed her birthday.
-Wow!
-So I just -- I also --
I just want to take
this opportunity to say hello,
Frankie Dibona.
-Yeah.
-We love you.
If anybody needs
some car repairs in Yonkers,
-Look him up.
-please look him up.
And please watch
our Hallmark movie.
-Yeah. This is cool.
You're going to announce tonight
that you are, in fact,
leaving Brad for Frankie?
-No!
-No, no, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, let's not make news.
We'll be right back with more
from Kimberly Williams-Paisley
and Ashley Williams.